bonjour à tous merci pour cette
invitation à débattre si je peux dire
avec l'opex donc jean françois
delfraissy je suis médecin je suis eux
auraient soeur d'immunologie et mai
rieter paris saclay j'ai dirigé
longtemps l' agence nationale de
recherches sur le sida et les hépatites
puis ensuite je me suis yeux très
impliqués dans les maladies émergentes
en particulier d'henri bola et donc j'ai
été nommé prétendu de ses qualités
scientifiques que vides début mars 2001
sur lesquels on pourra revenir je suis
fondamentalement donc un médecin et un
scientifique qui a dirigé une unité
inserm
je ne suis pas comme on me présente
souvent un conseiller médical qui a
suivi les présidents successifs il se
trouve qu'il ya eu plusieurs reprises
successives mais mon métier de base et
qui reste mon métier j'ai encore une
consultation à bicêtre
c'est d'être un médecin et auprès des
patients alors que tout ce que vous
parler du passé je vais vous parler de
ceux de notre vision actuelle au niveau
du conseil scientifique
enfin fin décembre quand je présentais
un peu le finalement sur un topo un peu
général de deux seuls de ce g de cette
pandémie je savais en sorte de tragédie
en trois actes la première qui
correspondait au à la première vague de
la seconde de la deuxième vague et la
troisième qui débutait à partir de
janvier 2021 et qui était finalement la
sortie un peu de cette tragédie avec
avec l'arrivée des vaccins plus
rapidement qu'on ne l'avait imaginé et
qui nous menait après des stratégies
vaccinales qui est états à mettre en
place et et qu'on s'a les comptes de
toute façon sa vie d'avant ce qu'elle
serait longue qui pouvait nous mener à
une sorte d'immunité en population pour
l'été et donc avec une sortie de crise
je dirais à l'automne
2020 tirs et puis juste avant noël tout
a changé c'est confirmé mais
malheureusement tout début janvier avec
l'arrivée des variants et je vous
rappelle très vite un bureau sauvé et
qu'on a on en même temps l'arrivée de
plusieurs variants en variant que
j'appellerais uk je vais je les ai
appelé par leurs noms de pays ce qui
n'est pas bien mais qui est plus simple
que si je vous inflige le 501 ira exact
3 etc
auquel cas est plus complexe mais ce
n'est pas bien parce qu'évidemment il ya
une sorte de forme d'ostracisme en
parlant de ça mais c'est génial on sait
bien on se souvient tous les débats sur
l'appellation grippe espagnole
voila voila n'avait rien d'espagnol et
s'étendant les vraiment attention
alors on va parler quand même néanmoins
de duke et appaloosa avait faim fin
septembre en angleterre puis qui a
progressé très rapidement les anglais
ont des capacités de séquençage
importante donc l'ont mis en évidence
d'une part cette pénétration en
particulier dans la région de l'ombre et
dans le sud est de l'angleterre puis son
extension et ont rapidement finalement
montré qu'il avait un niveau de
transmission qui était plus élevé si on
part d'un d'ailleurs zéro classique 1
pour eux je dirais le pari en normal là
c'est à dire l'absence de variants eh
bien on estime que le variant angles est
à 1.4 il n'est pas plus pathogène 1
contrairement à ce qui a été un peu
annoncé il ya eu des doutes au départ
sur sa capacité de transmission élu
est-ce que c'était un fait scientifique
ou est-ce que c'était une utilisation
politique par le collègue a lu
discussions au niveau des médecins des
épidémies magique sur le sujet
maintenant les choses sont claires il ya
véritablement un facteur de transmission
élevé ce qui a conduit donc à une
majorité de se marier en mariant par
exemple de mines qui est il devenu
majoritaire et est donc avec un niveau
de transmission et donc avec un niveau
de contamination est donc avec une
surcharge du système de soins et que
vous connaissez à l'ombre et qui a
conduit d'angleterre à se confiner de
façon drastique à partir juste de noël
vont aussi que l'angleterre était avec
des des conditions de
une précaution sanitaires beaucoup moins
élevées que celles qui étaient en france
et ça reste ça resterait sur le fond en
pratique et sur le port du masque sur
l'ouverture d'un certain de de lieu
l'exposition
donc on était dans un modèle différent
sur environ le il lit après trois
semaines de presque quatre semaines de
confinement il commence à voir la courbe
se casser à londres je rappelle qu'il ya
eu avec un décalage eu l'aval chose en
irlande avec un décalage de 15 jours à 3
semaines aussi en voilà l'augmentation
du haillan et qu'on a un autre modèle
qui a été très difficile aussi c'est le
modèle portugais
à l'occasion des fêtes de noël et du
jour de l'an y ait beaucoup 2 2 je
dirais d'interpénétration avec des
portugais qui travaillent en dehors du
portugal le variant angles est arrivé il
était à 6 % la première semaine à 14 %
la deuxième semaine
il est à 23% la deuxième semaine donc ce
variant et est en france on a pour sa 1
système de de surveillance via le
séquençage qui était moins moins
élaborées quand l'angleterre qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas non plus nuls comme je
l'entends parfois il ya une capacité de
séquençage qui est importante elle doit
être augmentée elle et elle est en train
de re il est en cours d'augmentation
d'ailleurs et il faut pas opposer une
stratégie de surveillance via les tests
pcr avec une stratégie de séquençage il
nous faut de la surveillance avec des
tasses pcr et du séquençage et c'est
vraiment les deux qui est l'un appuyant
l'eau alors on a les derniers chiffres
on a des enquêtes une grande enquête qui
a été réalisée donc les 8 et 9 janvier
une deuxième enquête réalisée hier mais
on a aussi des données en région
parisienne de réaliser par les ensembles
des laboratoires de virologie qui à
l'ensemble des techniques pour le
réaliser et globalement on est
maintenant pratiquement à 14% à paris on
est probablement autour de 9 à 10 % dans
la région sud de la france il ya une
grande hétérogénéité selon les régions
avec des régions qui sont beaucoup moins
touchés
c'est d'ailleurs le cas aussi en
angleterre où il ya aussaresses quand
même avec un une série de région d'oka
il ya des différends
mais toutes les régions sont touchées y
compris en france mais avec des niveaux
de pénétration du virus qui est qui et
maria sur ceux des grandes questions
évidemment vous avez le ce de ce variant
c est il sensible ou val st gall à la
réponse immunitaire induite par les
vaccins et la réponse est pour l'instant
oui très probablement ce sont les
données à la fois avec des deux vaccins
de type de type mais reina où les
données sont plutôt rassurantes de la
même façon que la neutralisation par des
cocktails d'anticorps monoclonaux ou par
des sérums de sujets déjà ayant fait un
co vide et il ya une neutralisation de
qualité sur le ring le variant sud
africaine est encore plus difficile si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi puisqu'il a une
à niveau de transmission qui est un
petit peu plus élevé que que le que le
variant angles est apparu des mois de
novembre décembre en afrique du sud
afrique du sud un réseau de recherche
qui est de très haut niveau qui s'est
construit autour du vih pratiquement 15
% des patients d essai pivot de phase
iii des essais de moderna et de phison
ont été réalisés en afrique du sud pour
vous montrer le le niveau que ça
représentait à raison de très connu de
vaccinologie en particulier il
il a comme particularité lui d'être avec
un niveau de transmission légèrement
plus élevé que l'anglais peut-être des
formes cliniques un tout petit peu
différente et un tout petit peu plus
précoce donc
et enfin le dernier point est que
malheureusement une série de données
suggèrent que les anticorps monoclonal
ne le neutralisent pas et les des
anticorps de ces deux patients ayant
fait un qu'ovide de neutralisent pas non
plus pour le vaccin c'est des données
qui sont le verre à moitié plein le
verre à moitié vide
certaines données suggèrent qu'ils aient
de neutralisation par l'aîné des sérums
de sujets curité vacciner
d'autres données en gros il ya trois
papiers qui sont sortis dans la dernière
semaine montre qu' à une perte de
sensibilité aux vaccins de l'ordre de
40%
le variant brésilien il ya deux types de
brésis 1 milliards donc en parler d'un
seul parent d'engis pour juste pour les
fier quand vous dites perte de
sensibilité vous entendez quoi ici
parcelles c'est à dire une perte quand
on analyse ensuite quand on prend deux
n'ont pas le virus sauvage mais des
souches qui ont été reconstitués avec
l'habitation correspondant au virus
sauvage qu'on prend ensuite des sérums
de sujets qui ont été vaccinés et
ensuite quand on compare la capacité de
ces sérum à neutraliser la souche
ancestrales ou au contraire la souce sud
africaine eh bien on s'aperçoit que les
sérums donc c'est bien une réponse
anticorps est uniquement de deux cd des
sujets vaccinés neutralise la souche sud
africaine mais avec une diminution
d'environ 40% en terme de titre la
souche brésilienne est donc dans le nord
et les forêts du brésil au tour de
manaus
c'est à peu près la même histoire que la
souche sud africaine elles émanent
neutralisé par des anticorps
neutralisants elle émane neutralisé par
les anticorps de sujets ayant déjà fait
un peu vide et elle et on a très peu de
données sur la sensibilité au vaccin
alors ce qui est je reviendrai sur les
questions qui se posent à partir de là
mais et c'est la question qui se pose à
particules pour la france là dans les
semaines qui viennent si on réfléchit
d'une sorte de philosophie de la
relation entre entre l'autre c'est le
virus pourquoi ces variants sur vient-il
au bout d'un an de que vite quelle est
l'explication est ce qu'on est passé à
côté
deux variantes qui serait survenue de
façon antérieurs non il ya des systèmes
de surveillance de l'eau niveau au
niveau planétaire de les séries de
laboratoire de virologie ce n'est site
de l'om est sous ou d'autres très grands
laboratoires qui sait quand serait
régulièrement et qui sur baïse entre
guillemets des variations importantes de
lutte en permanence à il ya une petite
mutation qui ont été acharnées on est
peut-être à la deux
150e la 300e but à sion mais aucune
d'entre elles n'avait entraîné de
modification phénotypiques c'est à dire
se traduisent en soit par une
transmission accrue soit par une
pathogénicité accrue placé en
l'occurrence ceux dont on parle pour ces
variants c'est essentiellement un
facteur de transmission accrue
je vous rappelle m passant de 1 à 1.4 ou
1.5 ce qui est quand même extrêmement
significatif alors pourquoi pourquoi
c'est varié en bout d'un an
alors l'autre point d'intérêt et le fait
que le variant basilien survient à
manaus manaus est considéré par les
épidémiologistes comme la ville qui
avait atteint une immunité en population
qui était de l'ordre de 70%
ça a été extrêmement touché par des
vagues successives dans des conditions
sanitaires très difficile au brésil
c'est une population très jeune à manaus
un général il ya eu beaucoup de décès
parmi les populations les plus âgées
mais l'immense majorité des cas était
survenu sur la population jeune et qui
avait été donc infectés avec la présence
d'anticorps c'est ce qu'on appelle cette
immunité en population
on se rappelle que l'objectif des
vaccins est d'arriver à et finalement il
dit militer en population de l'ordre de
70%
eh bien c'est ce qu'était obtenir manaus
pourquoi ça marche pas pourquoi manaus a
finalement l'arrivée d'un nouveau
variant qui n'est pas reconnue par les
anticorps précédent et ça pose la
question de la capacité du virus qui par
définition à des mutations un peu
aléatoire c'est l'avis de virus mais qui
peut être éventuellement dirigé par une
pression de sélection immunologique en
population ou au niveau individuel pour
sélectionner tel ou tel type de mutation
qui lui permet d'échapper entre
guillemets ce qu'on appelle un
échappement et militaires qui lui permet
d'échapper à finalement quelque chose
qui le neutralisent
alors pourquoi le variant sud africain
où il a été évoqué que parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de patients
immunodéprimés je rappelle que l'afrique
du sud est le pays qui a le plus long
terme axe lui le plus grand nombre de
patients vih qui est traitée plus ou
moins bien traité et donc une des
explications avaient été que c'est
s'assurer les plus vite chez les
patients
privé l'autre l'autre constatations ce
n'est pas une explication et le fait
qu'au cas on était on avait atteint 45%
d'immunité populationnelle et que au cas
on voit survenir un virus qui échappe
également aux anticorps neutralisants
chez les sujets du cac alors ça c'est ça
et évidemment sa scène un petit trouble
sur la relation je dirais entre haute et
ont été reçus par contre je vous rassure
ce n'est pas le cas le modèle ne marche
pas pour l'angleterre et le variés
anglais se comporte de façon très
différente et enfin la limite est
induite par les vaccins a probablement
une immunité plus forte plus solide plus
durable que l'immunité induite par
l'infection elle même et donc
s'installer mans qui est quand même à
prendre en compte dans ce tableau un peu
un peu gris que je vous donnais il ya un
élément positif qui est autour de la
réponse immune immunitaire induite par
le vaccin qui est probablement plus
forte que la réponse immunitaire induite
pour l'infection
alors je termine rapidement pour que
vous puissiez pour me poser des
questions et qu'en est-il au niveau
français à partir des premières données
c'est à dire qu'en france on a
finalement eu de double infection en ce
moment on avait une affection une
circulation du virus à un niveau
relativement important
la france est plutôt bon élève dans la
situation actuelle au niveau européen
après avoir était pas être passé par des
parts départ des périodes variables mais
quand on le compare par rapport à
l'angleterre par rapport à l'allemagne
qui avait été très bons élèves qu'on
nous qu'on nous donnait en permanence
par rapport aux suisses par rapport aux
belges par rapport à l'espagne par
rapport au portugal l'état sanitaire je
dirais l'état de de multiplication du
lycée et de contrôle de ce virus est
probablement plus adapté donc on à faire
une double circulation une circulation
du virus ancestrale est née une
circulation du nouveau mi-temps qui
pénètre de façon rapide puisque je vous
dis on met à peu près 14 % en région
parisienne et et je vois mal ce qui
pourrait l'arrêter entre guillemets mais
les mesures de de couvre-feu permettent
ont permis de tenir cette situation qui
est déjà très
milon terme de retentissement sur le
système sanitaire en termes d'occupation
des lits en termes de nouvelles
hospitalisations la dérision de france
je le savais qu'ils sont en situation de
tension en particulier en franche comté
ont donc dans le sud de la france
mais il ya aussi des situations qui sont
maintenus comme le en région parisienne
par exemple où la situation et est
maintenu mais il arrivait du variant
quand on fait des projections et à
l'intérieur des conseils scientifiques
ou le savez nous avons nous travaillons
avec eux avec que des scientifiques et
qui sont des modélisateurs et le conseil
scientifique du travail avec bien sûr
les membres des conseils scientifiques
mais chaque membre du conseil
scientifique est une tête de pont de sa
communauté et santé et redescend vers sa
communauté sont donc les modèles ne sont
pas les modèles d'un seul homme
ces modèles d'une communauté tient
derrière et avec plusieurs plusieurs
modélisateurs et nous montre que si on
suit le enfin en prenant quelque chose
de pente entre guillemets de type modèle
anglais eh bien on va se trouver dans
une situation à peu près à la mi mars
avec un virus extrêmement dominant avec
un facteur de transmission très élevé et
donc avec des conséquences sanitaires en
termes de 2,2 spitz alisation
d'hospitalisation en réa de 2,2 de
toucher la population la plus ancienne
et la plus fragile de façon importante
d'où la question posée avec l'arrivée de
ces variants une situation qui était
dans un équilibre fragile et
déséquilibrée par l'arrivée d'un variant
ayant une capacité de transmission
beaucoup plus élevé que le variant que
le le virus ancestrale de invariants sud
africain qui est déjà en place comme je
voulais 10 à plus petit niveau de 1 2%
mais qui va évidemment s'étendre par
ailleurs donc c'est une vraie question
donc que peut-on faire entre guillemets
et quelles décisions qu'il avait
évidemment pas du comité scientifique
mais qui sont des décisions politiques
je suis bien clair là dessus comme
spécifique n'est là que pour éclairer et
donné les enjeux aux gros pouvoir
politique alors un point par mais qui
est vraiment une question très
importante à mes yeux c'est l'outre-mer
la france en effet à des relations
vous le savez avec à la fois des
départements de avec la guyane d'une
part qui est très proche
finalement dans une vision de la région
de manaus enfin les forêts de mélèzes la
frontière n'existe pas il ya toujours eu
des passages on le sait dans les deux
sens
normalement cet horizon de ian qui a
fait l'objet d'une d'une vague très
importante à l'été et qui était un peu
protégés entre guillemets par
l'inversion de la saison puisque ce
virus est relativement sensible dans ses
relations avec le climat là va se
trouver avec une pénétration du virus
ceux du variant du brésilien qui est en
train de se faire un essai il est
illusoire de penser qu'on va pouvoir
l'arrêter en cup qui connaît la guyane
c'est qu'on ne pourra pas l'arrêter il
va passer dans nos territoires de guyane
même chose si du côté de l'océan indien
où ce virus chez l'africain est déjà
très remontés montre très vite le long
de la côte est de l'afrique au
mozambique 1 où il ya oui oui et on nous
avons l'idée un goût de cas importés du
mozambique eu récemment en france et qui
surtout il ya des liens importants avec
la réunion et mayotte et mayotte est
dans une situation sanitaire de fonds
indépendamment du coc vide qui est déjà
extrêmement difficile de vous le savez
pour de multiples raisons et qui la
vallée était probablement avec un
variant sud africain qui a trait à déjà
très largement très très largement paie
les frais alors mayotte et une
population très jeune donc là là là
conséquences sur la population mayotte
en général sera relativement faible en
termes de 2,2 sur sur les conséquences
en terme d'entrées sur les quelques les
des radis nation qu'ils ont glacé
finalisation sauf que évidemment c'est
une situation avec la virus qui se
transmet beaucoup qui va quant à elle
être extrêmement tendue dans les
semaines qui viennent
la réunion qui est un autre modèle les
premières données que nous avons
montrent que les rues si l'africain est
déjà de l'ordre de 5 à 6%
donc voilà je termine là dessus pour
vous indiquer que donc à nos yeux
l'arrivée de ces variants pour toute une
série de questions d'ordre scientifique
de fond un de philosophie une fois de
plus de la relation entre virus ou
réponse immunitaire delà de la
sensibilité au vaccin est en train de
modifier la donne
certains ont parlé d'une épidémie dans
l'épidémie d'autres d'une deuxième
pandémie moi je crois que c'est
l'histoire naturelle ont fait est qu'on
va avoir des variants des variants qu'il
va y en avoir d'autres un docu chose les
des outils de surveillance adaptée pour
le faire et ce et se donner en termes de
vaccination une très grande souplesse
très grande souplesse sur la
construction des vaccins et surtout bien
pensé qu' il faut qu'on maintienne en
termes de vaccins et jeu sinon c'est
vous avez écouté alain fischer et je ne
vais pas rentrer je dirais on est très
en phase en sabre est très souvent dopé
chaussons centre est clair qu'il ya
aucune aucune équivoque à cet égard mais
ça montre bien ses sensibilités
un peu diminué à certains vaccins pour
certains de ses vermillon l'importance
de conserver une réponse immunologique
parfaitement forte et adapté et donc de
respecter les règles sur la vaccination
merci beaucoup pour cette introduction
avant de passer la parole au rapporteur
je vais rappeler pour celles et ceux qui
nous suivent qu'il ya possibilité aussi
de poser des questions sur la plateforme
mise à disposition par l'assemblée
nationale à partir de la page web de
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
partie la page web de l'opex tu vous
retrouver à la une la fiche de 7-2 cette
audition et vous pouvez suivre le lien
qui est indiquée pour poser vos
questions il ya déjà un certain nombre
de questions en ligne
je vais donner la parole aux députés
jean françois illy à où l'un des
rapporteurs je vais commencer par les
rapporteurs
merci monsieur le président mon cher
qu'avec mon cher jean-françois merci
d'être là c'est vraiment très important
et très intéressant de de pouvoir
discuter avec vous
ou alors vous savez que le texte a une
mission j'irai constitutionnel dans la
mesure où on est là comme parlementaire
pour évaluer les contrôles et les
politiques publiques et l'action du
gouvernement et c'est donc dans cette
action là que dans ce cadre là que nous
nous situions et donc je vous posais
deux séries de questions de deux types
de questions la première deux premiers
types c'est concerne la partie de
l'american et scientifique
il ya des variants vous avez bien
expliqué c'est très clair il ya le
vaccin c'est également très clair et evo
les explications sur la relation hot hot
microbes ou audi russe est évidemment
l'importance de l'immunité antiviral
vous l'avez clamant également énoncé moi
j'ai une question qui concerne justement
le risque d'échappement le lier à la
pression de sélection exercée sur le
virus et on n'est pas étonné de ça et
vous l'avez bien expliquer également qui
pourrait être et joue entre avis
là-dessus qui pourrait être due la
conséquence des mesures que nous prenons
actuellement des mesures sanitaires que
nous prenons ces mesures sanitaires
pourquoi j ça c'est parce que ces
mesures sanitaires sont plus ou moins
efficaces mais on a vu quand même de
refi qu'à citer cet été avant le rebond
pour diminuer d'épidémie de la touche
ancestrales les vaccins également arrive
et est ce que c'est une question
scientifique est ce que ça ne le fait
pas le lit quelque part de l'émergence
d'un certain nombre de variants avec les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
qui serait pas forcément dirigée contre
la population des personnes âgées
mais plutôt dans le dans ce cadre là
vers la population plus jeune avec des
conséquences qui ne serait pas forcément
pathologique mais qui serait paralysante
pour la société et également avec un
risque puis à d'infection plusieurs de
risque de formes graves
c'est la première question est ce que
l'émergence de nouveaux variants la
pression de sélection est garé sur le
virus n'est pas favorisé facilitée par
les mesures que nous prenons et on est
obligé de les prendre y compris y
compris bien entendu la vaccination et
les conséquences que cela peut avoir en
termes de conséquences bien entendu on
est on a parlé du séquençage des cas
passés de séquençage mais on sait tous
que le séquençage n'est pas une
technique de routine pour faire des
diagnostics particulier via une silvio
logique donc quid des kits qui
permettraient non non pas d'avoir une
suspicion de l'appareil sur un nouveau
variant mais être plutôt en veille pour
dessiner d'emblée des kits qui pourrait
faire le diagnostic comme ça c'est fait
pour vh1 village de l'état pour voir les
différentes souches afin d'être plus
peut être précis dans les statistiques y
être plus en amont d'une réponse
sanitaire ou ou thérapeutique vis-à-vis
de c2c de ces nouvelles souches virales
de ces variants on peut multiplier les
plates formes de séquençage bien entendu
mais jamais on arrivera à la souplesse
que l'on a avec des kits que l'on peut
faire pratiquement chez soi et qui nous
permettrait d'avoir une vision beaucoup
plus précise de la dissémination de ces
virus
de la même façon et ton assez agile et
vous l'avez peut-être évoquez dans votre
dans vos derniers propos et ton assez
agile sur la préparation permettant
d'anticiper l'arrivée de nouveaux
vaccins qui serait plus adapté sachant
que les variances ont connu leur
séquence est connue et que notamment
avec des virus avec à partir d'un arn
synthétique géré il est facile de
synthétiser des vaccins après faut-il
encore qu'il soit efficace et c'est avec
ça mais en tout cas est-ce qu'on est
dans cette 2 dans cette situation là
c'était la première série de questions
scientifiques y sont tous premiers la
deuxième question concerne les relations
que
le conseil scientifique et que vous avez
personnellement avec l'ex difficile et
ça on n'est plus dans le dans notre
mission de contrôle et d'évaluation dans
la mesure où effectivement plus on se
rapproche du corps médical et je sais de
quoi je parle plus on est inquiet puis
on est en alerte plus bas et la relation
est parfois peut-être un peu compliqué
parce que bas parce que les politiques
ne comprennent pas à la science vous
propose dernière la science mais parce
qu'ils ont d'autres contraintes
et comment se fait cette relation alors
par personnel parce qu'on n'a pas
forcément ça m'intéresse pas de savoir
si nous aurons des bancs publics c'est
pas ça la question
mais quel est votre puissance d'impact
si je peux dire en tant qu' en tant que
le conseil scientifique et vous en tant
que président de ce conseil scientifique
joueurs merci merci beaucoup chers
collègues à quoi semble et un coup sénat
la parole à la sénatrice sonia de la
provôté oui professeur merci beaucoup
voilà deux autres de vos propos
liminaire qui ont amené déjà beaucoup
d'informations moi j'ai deux questions
la première est celle d'une montée en
puissance dans la population de une
acceptabilité moins bonne en matière de
confinement et de mesures annoncées qui
sont clairement mal vécu on voit ça et
là des formes de révolte des restaurants
ouverts et c'est tant le poids a
finalement de l'impact social sociétal
et économique de ce conflit depuis un an
et pèse sur les personnes et du coup a
tendance à amoindrir la prise de
conscience du risque sanitaire et moi ce
que j'aimerais savoir c'est comment
comment vous voyez la façon de
communiquer parce que effectivement vous
l'avez dit très bien on est dans une
situation certes pas encore à la cne à
l'acmé mais c'est le moment où il faut
agir en amont
et comment voyez vous une communication
simple intelligible et qui pour
convaincre nos concitoyens d'affronter à
nouveau des mesures de restriction et un
confinement et si je dis ça c'est parce
que par exemple le couvre-feu à 18
heures çà et là on entend des doutes sur
son efficacité est finalement un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été prises
montrent que ça contribue à moindre
accès acceptabilité de la population et
donc sur les variants en réalité est ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas avoir un discours
aussi clair que celui que vous venez
d'avoir mais aussi peut-être un seul
canal de communication parce que les
interventions d'un certain nombre un
interlocuteur institutionnel ou non font
que le doute s'installe et je pense que
l'acceptabilité va être très difficile
or en l'état actuel des choses le
confinement est la seule mesure qu'on a
trouvée pour diminuer la circulation
virale
on n'a pas atteint le taux d'immunité en
population nécessaire pour pouvoir
diminuer cette circulation et donc
j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue sur
les voies et moyens pour que cette
prochaine mesure qui va arriver puisse
être accepté et quels sont pour vous les
arguments clés sur lesquels il faut
absolument s'appuyer pour pouvoir
convaincre tout le monde de cette
nouvelle mesure
moi je voudrais aussi posé une question
sur sur le séquençage dans le séquençage
donc on est on est vraiment très axé sur
le variant britannique uk qui comme on
dit on sait qu'il y a les autres variant
leurs taux de pénétration en france
c'est pas du tout de la même importance
mais en réalité n'en sommes pas du tout
exempté et le variance ultra sud
africain pourrait très bien apparaître
avec sa puissance même supérieur de
diffusion par rapport aux variants et
britanniques
comment dans l'organisation du
séquençage nationale on est en capacité
proprement d'avoir un état des lieux de
l'arrivée de ces variants et pensez vous
puisqu'on voit quand même qu'à une
région régionalisation même en
angleterre il ya une régionalisation ne
pensez vous pas que dans ces mesures que
nous devrions prendre prendre en compte
et mettent en place comme les mesures de
confinement ne pensez pas que ne pensez
vous pas que la régionalisation ou la
départementalisation d'un forte en tout
cas la territorialisation de certaines
mesures pour être une façon efficace
pour pouvoir
confiné en quelque sorte ces variants
dans un secteur dans lesquels on
pourrait si ce n'est des etam en tout
cas diminuer largement leur diffusion à
l'échelle du pays
jean merci merci chers collègues la
parole au député gérard le seul
rapporteur lui également merci président
merci professeur de du temps que vous
nous consacrer j'aurai trois rapide
question à vous poser
vous l'avez dit nous en sommes tous
convaincus les vaccins constituent l'
espoir majeur pour limiter l'impact de
voir pour résoudre en grande partie la
pandémie de la copie de 19 mais vous
nous avez un petit peu inquiété tout à
l'heure on disant que finalement ce qui
avait été initialement prévu c'est à
dire une sortie à l'automne 2021 et est
repoussé pensez vous que dans ce
contexte le fait d'avoir pour le moment
vacciner un million de français nous
mais globalement dans les clous c'est à
dire est ce que nous sommes dans les
temps pour permettre de diminuer les
pics d'hospitalisation comme vous
l'indiquiez dans votre avis dur et du 12
janvier dernier
deuxième question toujours dans votre
avis du 12 janvier qui était très
intéressant dans les points clés
d'ailleurs eu ou
avait résumé vous indiquez et je
rejoindrai ma collègue sonia de la
provôté qui vous a interpellé tout à
l'heure sur le sujet vous indiquez que
plus les décisions sont prises
rapidement plus elles sont efficaces et
plus elles permettent d'éviter des
mesures de restrictions sanitaires plus
dur dans un second temps et dans une
certaine mesure vous faisiez des
propositions qu'en est il aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de trop
temporiser est ce qu'il y à des mesures
d'urgence à prendre rapidement et puis
troisième question qui remonte beaucoup
en tout cas dans ma circonscription sur
les réseaux sociaux je vais rencontrer
aussi des collectifs de médecins que
pense le conseil scientifique que
pensez-vous de la recommandation de
l'académie de médecine
concernant de supplémenter
préventivement toutes les personnes 46
en vitamine d
je vous remercie par avance merci
beaucoup chers collègues la parole la
sénatrice florence lassarade acier
président merci professeur de nous
déchirer à nouveau
j'ai écouté votre interview sur bfm tv
je crois que c'était mardi matin vous
étiez extrêmement alarmiste vis-à-vis de
la population pour apparemment à
préparer un confinement rapide ce
confinement en fait on attend toujours
le couvre-feu paris plus ou moins
efficaces plus ou moins respecté
c'est vrai que quand on est médecin on
se pose également d'autres questions
assez simple visa ville des deux
extrémités de la vie moi je suis
pédiatre à vous savez donc je pense que
les parents sont inquiets de savoir ce
qu'on va faire de nos enfants
nicolas vous n'avez pas parlé de l'âme
diffusion pédiatrie de ses variantes
on a dit que les enfants seraient
vraisemblablement plus contagieux avec
ces variants là haut est ce que c'est
parce qu'on disait est ce que c'est
parce qu'on disait en mars
2000 rats on avait envisagé de fermer
les classes et d'ailleurs les enfants
étaient complètement qu'en chine et
parce qu'on les pensait très contagieux
escales à nouveau c'est pas c'est pas le
sujet finalement parce que depuis qu'ils
portent le masque à l'école il semble
qu'ils se contentent kangur bus dans
leur famille et c'est ce que ce que dit
la société française de pédiatrie qu'il
recommence surtout de ne pas confiné des
enfants qui ont des problèmes
du coup assez psychologique assez assez
important on sait que les étudiants
souffrent également terriblement de la
situation depuis un an
j'en viens à la santé mentale finalement
de toute la population
est ce que est ce que on peut considérer
que ce couvre feu suivi d'un confinement
probable l'angoissent que ça peut
générer à l'avancé ce qui vaudrait pas
mieux dire bon allez on y va on confie
nantes en cours qu'est-ce qu'elle votre
influence sur les décisions du
gouvernement à ce sujet ensuite on a
parlé lahlou d'un check up si sur les
étudiants je sais pas si c'est là tu
leur mets l'état à la hauteur de
dégradations psychologique koninck a
constaté et dernière sur mac et mickael
beaucoup parce que j'ai un ccas dans la
dans la commune en a fait une enquête
pour savoir quelle personne depuis de 75
ans on a mené au centre de vaccination
est d'ailleurs très très proche à
quelques kilomètres
si tenté qu'un jour l'année les vaccins
arrivent jusque là il ya énormément de
refus de vaccination chez cette tranche
de population que tel parce que je suis
en mode à l'aquitaine qui a été peu
touché par l'épidémie mais néanmoins
c'est très très très alarmant quand on
sait que le pays compte y est et est à
l'arrêt parce que on craint pour nos
aînés une arrivée en réanimation
- oui je me demande s'il n'aurait pas
fait à lui préconisé une obligation
vaccinale comme on l'a fait pour les
jeunes enfants
le vaccin est ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû
préconisé une obligation vaccinale pour
cette tranche de population j'ai peur
qu'on se heurte une fois que les lacs
symbole
à ce sujet les dernières questions alors
plus technique il semblerait quand même
que le kaiser du high tech et le modern
art puisse s'adapter aux variants et
soit pas si inefficace que ça sur le
futur logo sur les variants quand les
petits par contre des vaccins base
dindinaud virus
astrazeneca ou d'autres d'autres vaccins
puits traditionnels je ne parle pas du
nôtre qu'on a abandonné
c'est ça m'amène à poser la question
également de la fierté française sur le
sur ses capacités à produire un vaccin
voilà sur mercier merci beaucoup merci
chers collègues ça fait beaucoup de
questions j'ajouterai deux questions
très brève dans ce dans ce premier tour
professeur vous nous évoquer évidemment
il ya aussi des aspects on l'a vu dans
certaines des questions d esprit qui
relève des sciences humaines et sociales
des questions psychologiques ce que vous
nous rappeler qu'elle est là rapport au
conseil scientifique dans son
fonctionnement
quelles sont les compétences que vous
avez en interne les différentes
spécialités quelles sont celles sur
lesquelles vous avez cherché des avis
ailleurs calé lequel le mode de
fonctionnement du conseil avec la
communauté scientifique
et puis j'ai une deuxième question vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure dans votre
propos de en gros trois vagues
je me souviens d'une audition dans
laquelle avec un épidémiologiste dans
lequel on expliquer bien que en vrai on
avait commencé à perdre le contrôle de
l'épidémie en juillet ou en août en tout
cas très tôt et que c'est jamais revenu
on a vu aussi que dans le deuxième
confinement n'est jamais redescendu en
dessous des seuils qu'on avait
prédéfinis pour
comme étant le retour à la normale
globalement qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
avec du recul sur l'ensemble dynamique
depuis depuis mars c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment trois vagues c'est pas non plus
un seul événement qu'est ce qu'on quels
enseignements on tire de tout ça voilà
pour ce sens semble ça fait beaucoup de
questions et on aura un deuxième tour de
questions après encore beaucoup de
questions correspondant à un sujet
extrêmement chargé bien sûr à vous la
parole professeurs tout d'abord le
conseil scientifique qui sommes-nous
comment fonctionne en nous et finalement
quelles sont nos relations avec avec les
les autorités sanitaires de ce pays
alors on est 12 le conseil scientifique
ça a été formé 10 mars à la suite d'une
réunion de scientifiques avait lieu à
l'elysée quelques jours précédemment
le conseil scientifique a été a été
formé avec des propositions que j'ai pu
faire et des propositions cacher le
ministre de la santé puis nous sommes
tombés d'accord sur un certain nombre de
noms je l'avais souhaité
multidisciplinaire il comprend en
particulier bien sûr virologues
animateurs infectiologues modélisateurs
épidémiologistes mais aussi un médecin
généraliste qui avait qui est impliqué
dans le collège de la chaise j'avais
souhaité également qui est des
scientifiques des sciences humaines et
sociales et nous avons re une
anthropologue spécialiste des maladies
émergentes et chercheurs du cnrs
professeur d'aider des politiques
publiques
la science nous avons une représentation
de la société civile pas suffisante à
mes yeux mais néanmoins présentes qui a
d'ailleurs été nommé au niveau du du
sénat avec la présidente de
l'association addes été carrément
demandé des sujets en grande précarité
car on rappelle que cette pandémie
comme toutes les grandes pandémies
touche évidemment est pleinement injuste
et touche bien sûr les populations les
plus fragiles
mais pas seulement liés à l'ajout ou à
des conditions physiques et aussi à des
conditions de précarité
nous fonctionnons on se réunit trois
fois par jour pendant les trois premiers
mois et on fonctionne chaque que chaque
scientifique et un peu tête de ponce
comme je l'indiquais tout à l'heure de
sa communauté
il a cherché un certain nombre d'idées
au sein de sa communauté
et puis on les fait remonter on saute
saisie en gros s'est autosaisie 2
environ trois quarts des des sujets et
c'est seulement un quart de saisine que
nous avons eu de la part des autorités
sanitaires
dernier point peut-être sur le sur le
mode de fonctionnement gelé souhaité que
les avis du conseil scientifique soit
publique
je rappelle que par exemple est
l'équivalent du conseil scientifique
anglais ils étaient anonymes d'une part
ils sont pas restés longtemps parce
qu'ils ont cessé vite sorti lui dans la
presse mais n'avait pas d'avis écrit moi
j'ai souhaité que vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens
les avis puissent être écrit que la
presse suisse les avoirs que les
différentes autorités essaient d'avoir
il ya un délai c'est à dire qu'on les
donne d'abord aux autorités sanitaires
et gouvernementales et puis ensuite il
ya des liens souvent de quelques jours
et entre temps il peut y avoir des
décisions de politiques qui ont été
prises en s'appuyant sur ses amis alors
que la vie sort légèrement après sur la
question posée toujours de relations du
conseil scientifique avec l'exécutif
bon je crois que c'est extrêmement clair
1 le conseil scientifique est là pour
éclairer l'exécutif il n'est pas là pour
décider de quoi que ce soit les
décisions sont des décisions et mais
éminemment politique et elles sont
prises par les politiques
voilà le le conseil scientifique met sur
la table un certain nombre de points qui
lui paraissent de point de situation
d'enjeux qui lui paraissent importants 2
points deux points difficiles de points
clés éventuellement c'est là où c'est
probablement le plus difficile à
comprendre pour la population on
s'appuie en effet sur on a une vision je
dirais nous sommes déjà pour vous pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée nous nous
sommes en train de réfléchir là
maintenant sur le post ce qui sera je ne
sais pas quoi
que décidera le politique au plus haut
niveau
c'est comment on sort d'une situation
aussi difficile que celle là ayez donc
on essaie en permanence d'anticiper un
peu les questions qui peuvent eux qui
peuvent se poser les relations donc avec
nos politiques nous nous suit ou ne le
suis pas ce sont des décisions
politiques c'est à lui de les prendre
je constate que dans beaucoup de cas il
nous a suivis et puis on a quelques
occasions en autant d'années 2,3 exemple
ou où il ne nous a pas suivis ou par
exemple sur l'école au mois deux au
moins de mai et où finalement l'exécutif
a souhaité réouvrir les écoles nous le
souhaitions les coller et les conserver
fermée jusqu'au mois de juillet et il a
eu raison
un après a posteriori me demander l'avis
que la vision que j'avais il y a eu
raison c'était parce que il ya
évidemment une vision sanitaire mais il
ya une vision sociétale et il ya une
vision économique et qui est en jeu que
nous avons aussi en est pas complètement
borne est donc temps de traverse à
lutter deuxièmement un deuxième élément
réclamé à que la constitution d'un
comité citoyen de liaison citoyenne de
discussions avec la société pour faire
remonter un certain nombre de coins pour
des raisons diverses des autorités ne
l'ont pas mis en place elles l'ont mis
en place le mieux vaut tard que jamais
avec autour depuis vaccins et du season
vous le savez depuis quelques temps
enfin dernier point c'est peut-être là
le point le plus sensible
c'est dans des situations difficiles on
sent bien que il y à une évolution que
la situation est un point est un point
clé un peu critique qui peut se poser
cette situation qu'on aille au mois de
septembre nous avons nous avons souligné
l'importance de la reprise de l'épidémie
et l'arrivée d'une deuxième vague entre
guillemets avec les nuances qu'on
pourrait y apporter et où il ya eu oui a
parfois à décalage entre le signal donné
par le conseil scientifique et la
décision politique
mais ce sont des décisions une fois de
plus très complexe on est également dans
cette période là où on a donné des
signaux et bien sûr la décision
politique sera prise je dirais donc je
ne sais pas quand d'ailleurs c'est une
décision qui sera prise par le politique
jeu sur ce dernier point la situation
actuelle je vous ai donné la situation
épidémiologique en france
je considère qu'on est dans quelque
chose due
jambes et je ne retire pas les paroles
sur l'idée que plus on prend une
décision vite plus ensuite les ailes et
les jeudis réel et neil lennon une
activité qui est importante
ne confondons pas l'urgence et l'extrême
urgence sur des décisions aussi complexe
que re confiné un pays quelles que
soient la ou en tout cas poursuivre un
couvre-feu
quelle que soit la décision qui sera
prise pour la politique c'est ça mérite
que les enjeux on le voit bien et vos
questions le montre bien que les enjeux
sanitaires soient évidemment les enjeux
importants mais ils ne sont pas les
seuls et sans enjeux sociétaux et son
jeu et d'acceptabilité des mesures les
enjeux de conséquences pour notre
jeunesse croyez que le comité
scientifique
je suis mon âme grand-père à gg j'ai
enfin on a on est on est des citoyens
comme les autres et on se rend
parfaitement compte des enjeux extra
sanitaire qui peuvent être existé et
donc de la difficulté des décisions donc
bien sûr on est dans une âme au mans où
il va falloir prendre des décisions est
ce que ces décisions et était depuis le
début de la semaine à un jour près comme
je l'entend partout
la réponse est donc prenons le temps
d'essayer de construire de façon
intelligente la moins mauvaise des
réponses pour construire autour de cela
donc voilà sur les relations entre le
comité scientifique et son mode de
fonctionnement une politique
après de très très nombreuses questions
un surhomme les diagnostics l'équipe de
séquençage etc
oui ils font pas non plus à l'aise qu'il
faut à la fois une stratégie de kits de
pcr des gnostiques vous avez
parfaitement raison
et puis à côté du séquençage mais il
faut pas non plus penser que tout va
résoudre que les séquençages vous êtes
au réseau les qui diagnostique pour
l'instant sont construits avec des psr
qui donne des signes d' alerte mais qui
ne donne pas des signaux positifs en
disant c'est tel ou tel type de variants
cela dit cpcr je dirais qu'ils
permettraient de discriminer et de dire
immédiatement si c'est invariant anglais
ou invariants sud africain nous allons
les avoir dans les jours ou dans les
semaines qui viennent
elles sont déjà construites par les
laboratoires de virologie à l'ap-hp et
elles vont être eux elles vont être
disponibles donc c'est exactement la
réponse à la question que vous posez par
ailleurs le séquençage oui
il est important néanmoins parce qu'il
permet une surveillance non après sans a
priori c'est à dire six en cinq ans on
est capable de voir arriver un nouveau
variant c'est ce qu'ont vu les anglais
les yeux qui n'était pas connu la
technique de pcr quart mais seulement
finalement d'avoir une surveillance
diagnostic d'invariants qu'on connaît
déjà et dont on connaît les mutations
c'est donc n'opposons pas les la
stratégie de technique de pcr monté avec
le santé publique france l'ensemble des
laboratoires de virologie et et soyons
un peu positif une fois de plus la
france est probablement le seul pays
d'europe qui est capable de sortir en ce
moment des chiffres assez précis sur
l'arrivée les variants je faisais donné
quelques chiffres au portugal par
exemple et en angleterre bien sûr mais
l'allemagne là aussi il a exactement la
pénétration de ces virus en allemagne
n'a pas le modèle de suivi et de
dépistage de séquençage que nous avons
mis en place
elle va l'avoir vérifié sur pas plus
idiot que nous sommes mais c'est pour
dire qu'on est aussi réactif sur un
certain nombre sur un certain nombre de
sujets l'agilité sur sur les variants et
la stratégie vaccinale
oui alors là les gens rentrent dans la
danse dans la région et elle accepte
donc je pourrais être bien clair à je
rappelle que les deux ex saint amé reina
finalement couvre et permettent
d'induire une réponse immunitaire et qui
permet de neutraliser le variant anglais
c'est comme ça le point essentiel la
juliet à tous partager ce soir et puis
si en effet il ya des pénétrations
d'autres variant les deux les techniques
de vaccins mais reina permettent
d'anticiper cela alors il ya il ya deux
questions qui sont sur la table autour
de ces vaccins et de l'arrivée
éventuellement de variants premièrement
il savait qu'on ne connaît pas la durée
exacte protection de réponse immunitaire
induite par ces vagues les deux dindes 8
par ces vaccins pour les cimes de
quelques mois après on sait pas trop et
il ya déjà une stratégie mené par par
ces compagnies et avec les scientifiques
d'ailleurs de se dire on pourrait
rebooster la réponse immunitaire
avec un nouveau une nouvelle vaccination
nouvelle vaccination
je dirais dirigé classiques comme
l'était le variant initiale ou bien
qu'entre à nouveau variant qui serait
capable c'est à dire une population
encore été vaccinée pour être vaccinés
au bout de neuf mois par exemple
ils sont en train de tester ça avec un
vaccin directement dédiés vis-à-vis de
telle ou telle variante et puis ils vont
plus loin et en discuter tout à l'heure
avec le avec eux à l'affiché et marie
paule kieny avec le le patron de de
modern art kiwi il consomme y sont en
train de construire la capacité de
vaccins et possédant plusieurs et mais
reina dirigée contre 2 contre différents
variant 1 c'est à dire des règles ça
pluri variant ils sont même en train
d'essayer de de construire des vaccins
qui permettrait à la fois de couvrir la
grippe et le coronavirus est-ce qu'ils
vont y arriver
point d'interrogation la technique en
tout cas le permet et ils ont déjà des
ils ont déjà un certain nombre de
données puisque des vaccins contenant
plusieurs m et rena sont actuellement
disponibles contre le cytomégalovirus 1
et c'était le c'était le vaccin sur
lesquels il s'était plongé avant
d'arriver sur le corps d'armes à derna
et ils ont déjà donc la caf pays savent
qu'on peut en plus petite quantité et
non pas où te haute avec les quantités
initiales du vaccin parce que sinon ça
ferait trop gros sur la quantité de la
rna mais deux ans plus petites quantités
on peut construire avec ça je dirais
pluri potentiels est dirigé contre
différents variant qui pourrait donc
s'adapter au fur et à mesure il faut
souhaiter g que con que je dirais la
pression vaccinale et c'est dans cette
balance entre la sélection des variants
et la pression vaccinale il faut
souhaiter que la pression vaccinale est
pour ça qu il faut vacciner vite et le
plus de personnes et bien le permettre
de ne pas non plus multiplier
je dirais la construction de vaccins
plus arriver rien parce que s'ils ont
des plans permanents ce en train de
colère derrière ça sera ça sera pas une
bonne chose
alors deuxième type de questions c'est
finalement le l'acceptabilité et là et
la crise
je dirais un peu sociétal autour de de
cette crise
je comprends parfaitement votre question
le conseil scientifique la comprends
parfaitement su si ça vous rassure tout
le monde en a assez et j'en ai assez moi
aussi mais moi ça n'a pas d'importance
mais à plus jeune qui est un jeune
étudiant qui est en première année qui
n'a jamais vu qu'il n'a jamais vu ses
potes un plus jeunes qui n'arrivent pas
à trouver de boulot à plus jeunes qui
n'arrivent pas à trouver de petites
amies le conseil scientifique sur sa
dimension humaine et sociale on a
pleinement conscience et c'est un enjeu
comment que nous construisons la balance
en train tout sanitaires tout sanitaire
c'est à dire c'est le choix qui a été
fait jusqu'à maintenant de protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles et plus
anciennes et des diminuer la morbidité
mortalité par rapport à une vision qui à
la fois et c'est de tenir le sanitaire
parce que je ne crois pas que les
français le sachent je m'avance à titre
personnel mais envie d'avoir des images
difficiles de de trop de décès parce que
c'est une vision de la société qui est
que nous avons tous un et qui est
complexe mais et versements qui permet
aussi et de d'avoir une france qui vit
et gelé je comprends tout à fait ce
n'est pas au conseil scientifique de se
prononcer là dessus
ce sont des sillons évidemment politique
je le dis néanmoins si vous voulez mais
poussée dans mes retranchements
je pense que nous sommes véritablement
avec une question un peu sociétale et
éthiques
quasi éthiques actuellement de
finalement de politique générationnel
entre continuer à préserver la santé des
plus anciens mais peut-être au détriment
de la santé des plus jeunes
et c'est une vraie grandes questions
auxquelles nous sommes très sensibles
alors la communication c'est un élément
fondamental
le conseil scientifique n'est pas là ce
n'est pas il n'est pas là pour
communiquer je vous rappelle qu'on est
on communique à l'occasion de la sortie
de nos avis pourrait très explicatif
j'essaie parfois de prendre la parole
mais vous avez qu pas tellement souvent
même si eux mêmes s'ils étaient prises
de parole sont se sont parfois
surdimensionnés par les médias pour
expliquer et je comprends parfaitement
votre expliqué des sujets difficiles
expliqué ce que vous disiez c'est à dire
finalement pour le français qui est
beaucoup plus intelligent comme le pense
bien sûr à chaque fois qu'est ce que ça
veut dire à marjah c'était un risque
théorique on lui raconte qu'on va être
qu'on va se trouver avec beaucoup plus
une pression sur les sur les services de
réanimation mi mars et ses amis
ivoiriens ils voient la france qui
continue l'a1
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué
d'expliquer comment l'arrivée d'un
variant en effet il faut avoir une
attitude préventive pour essayer
d'éviter d'avoir trop de retentissement
c'est le système de soins est trop
d'entrée en rénovation et de décès dans
la période de fin mars par exemple la
communication et la base de la confiance
la confiance vous le savez c'est un
phénomène fondamental dans les crises
quel que soit le type de crise et c'est
la confiance ce n est pas là d'emblée
elle se construit et on passe par et au
débat et je j'ai pleinement quand j'ai
pleinement conscience que de la même
façon qu'il ya parfois de des problèmes
de confiance entre le citoyen et
politique
il ya aussi il y a aussi des problèmes
de confiance entre le citoyen et les
scientifiques mais c'est un autre débat
que ce soir et que c'est une vraie leçon
à tirer est me semble-t-il de la crise
de la crise que vit le séquençage je
vous en ai déjà parlé ensuite l'espoir
avec les vaccins
oui oui les jeux les vaccins restent les
soirs un c'est fondamental ce que j'ai
voulu introduire c'est qu'on avait un un
schéma assez simple en début d'année
avec une sortie de crise pour pour la
mi-octobre enfin pour la pour le mois
d'octobre
on sent bien que ces voix là on
s'interroge sur la balle
finalement la survenue éventuellement
d'un autre variant qui pourrait qui
pourrait reposer une question on
s'interroge sur la durabilité des
vaccins mais aussi sur les réponses que
je vous ai dit
la capacité aussi l'algérie mène qui va
être capable de fabriquer de nouveaux
vaccins
on s'interroge également sur lie sur
finalement refaire rentrer dans une
sorte de vaccination chronique modifié
qu on modifierait chaque année vis-à-vis
de ce virus on est je dire il faut être
très prudent
il faut être très modeste vis-à-vis de
ce virus vraiment très mad as le 10 ans
tout rond toute franchise je on a je
pense me semble-t-il une sortie de crise
possible quand on aura vacciner
l'immense majorité des personnes qui
sont les plus à risque et toutes ne
seront pas vaccinés
parce que où il allait très bien il ya
des gens qui vont mais très peu de gens
qui vont refuser remonté à - yeux 1dans
dans cette population
il ya des gens qui suit il y aura une
réponse immunitaire qui sera moins bonne
si vous prenez 80% vacciner 80 % de
réponses nuits fauves 8,64 vous avez
quand même un tiers de cette population
qui du coup ne serait pas protégé donc
vous voyez que il faut à la fois mettre
beaucoup de choses dans les vaccins
mais penser à autre chose que les
vaccins et probablement les mois qui
viennent vont être un élément très
important pour autre chose que pour les
vaccins et devront être sur la
thérapeutique et sur la thérapeutique de
prise en charge des personnes les plus à
risque et d'un traitement immédiat dès
qu'on a un traitement possible
alors est-ce qu'on est suffisamment non
les mecs ça je les ai répondu chez les
sujets âgés les enfants oui les écoles
oui c'est un sujet évidemment qui écrit
à la fois très je dirais très technique
et très sociétale les données anglaise
qui initialement suggéré que le varia
anglais était plus transmissible au sein
des écoles et des enfants ne nous ont
pas convaincus
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
vu dans ma vie le fait que nous
recommandions y compris avec les
variants la poursuite de l'ouverture des
écoles parce que il ya d'autres enjeux
et vous avez pleinement conscience
qu'ils sont des enjeux sociétaux et en
particulier pour les enfants qui sont
des délits sud et des classes les plus
fragiles ou ou socialement défavorisés
nous restons pour l'instant sur cette
position
c'est à dire que si vous voulez quand
vous avez une circulation de sang des
virus en population générale
la siffler en général sudiste se chiffre
au hasard on peut le chiffrer dans le
même temps 60 chez les enfants tahir un
peu plus bas que dans la population
adulte
vous avez très bien dit que chez les
enfants étaient infectés par les adultes
et non la baisse mais quand vous avez
une circulation virale qui montent à 200
ch et chez les adultes
eh bien elle monte à 120 chez les
enfants c'est dire que les enfants sont
aussi un facteur de transmission mais
ils ne sont pas un facteur de
transmission particulièrement je dirais
impliqués dans la transmission de ces
variants donc c'est un enjeu qui est
évidemment totalement essentiel est pour
l'instant de récents sur notre position
si je regarde si ces mois ci au niveau
européen il ya la moitié la moitié la
moitié des pays européens ont choisi de
fermer les écoles
c'est le cas en angleterre par exemple
c'est le cas dans un certain nombre de
pays
puis la moitié d'autres pays européens
concernés a décidé de conserver les
écoles l'affluence des des six ans fin
des préconisations du conseil
scientifique sur les décisions du
gouvernement j'ai répondu tout à l'heure
c'est on sépare bien ce qu'est le
conseil scientifique qui est là pour
pour présenter un certain nombre d'états
des lieux et et d'éclairage sanitaires
et les décisions sont celles des
politiques on est une grande démocratie
l'idée qui cas car un peu germé dans la
tête des journalistes à une période
antisyrien troisième pouvoir médical en
france
j'oubliais immédiatement c'est archi
faux il ya bien sûr en cas de crise
sanitaire le pouvoir politique en temps
ou n'entend pas ce que dit
éventuellement les conseiller
scientifique au médicaux mais c'est la
même chose donc l'ensemble des pays les
décisions elles sont politiques
enfin sur la notion de vas y que je
posais monsieur minani oui vous avez
raison
peut-être c'est peut être un peu
simpliste c'est une position de première
vague de deuxième vague mais qui serait
une troisième bague avec les variants
c'est peut-être sur le front des tous
persuadés que c'est la même histoire
et puis qu'en fonction des mesures de
contrainte
et dédé de circulation de changement de
l'été qui arrive du brassage des
populations
eh bien on passera de toute façon l'idée
n'est pas de contrôler et d'année et de
l'es2 d'éradiquer ce re5 vous avez tous
compris ceux qui dès le maintenir à un
certain niveau qui permette et de
protéger en tout cas jusqu'à maintenant
c'était ça l'objectif de protéger en
priorité contre la morbidité et la
mortalité
les personnes les plus anciennes et les
plus fragiles première grande question
autour de la circulation du virus et de
la question aussi où on se contaminent
comment ce conte éviter une question
finalement le sait-on après presque un
an de pandémie
on commence à mieux le savoy à partir de
trois études qui sont toutes les trois
paru début décembre
awake c'est relativement récent une
étude américaine
mais l'étude anglaise et une étude
française menée par nous font aller
ainsi du pasteur à partir de la
déclaration de gens qui se sont été
contaminés qui rentre dans le modèle des
déclarations de déco vide et qui à qui
on demande s'ils sont volontaires pour
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions par mail expliqué ensuite
participé à cette enquête
alors ce qui ressort c'est que on se
contaminent lorsqu'on arrête de porter
le masque et qu'on mange et qu'on boit
soit à l'extérieur soit chez soi
ce sont on enlève son masque pour manger
et boire avec des amis de la famille
chez soi des amis à l'extérieur ce sont
les deux modes de contamination les plus
fréquents alors ça veut dire les bars et
les restaurants sont fermés c'est exact
d'ailleurs et l'épidémie continue on
entend parfois oui puisque en effet une
partie de la contamination et en
particulier chez les plus anciens
il faut bien ainsi si son côté vannes il
faut bien qu'on se pose la question où
il se contaminent et la plupart des
anciens font attention actuellement sauf
qu'ils sont pas suffisamment attention
pour se protéger
entre guillemets quand ils sont chez eux
vis-à-vis de leurs familles de leurs
amis des personnes qui viennent des voix
et que c'est le deuxième élément de
contamination il ya d'autres évidemment
il ya des repas et chaque fois qu'on
enlève son masque et les repas possible
dans l'errance terran d'entreprises sont
aussi possiblement a lieu de
contamination via une série d' endroit
qui qui par contre n'apparaissent pas
clairement parce que les gens sont en
france gens font très attention ne
citoyens les les médias nous montrent
essentiellement les minorités mais la
majorité des gens fait très attention
aux français l'a voulu
j'ai tout à l'heure il ya une population
qui a peur maintenant qui est inquiète
qui mais qui a été finalement
relativement sage jusqu'à maintenant
qu'un cas parfaitement toléré des
mesures extrêmement difficile auxi porte
le masque dont dans les transports et
les transports ne sont pas réellement
pas lieu de contamination à certain
nombre de commerces ne sont pas
réellement lieu de contamination
donc je tousse avant de dire que plus
une mesure que s'appuyer sur une donnée
scientifique
on peut raconter l'histoire à nos
citoyens et expliquer pourquoi tel ou
tel type de mesure est prise
plus elle est crédible plus en établir
un climat de confiance
mais malheureusement dans cette
pathologie les données que nous avons
elles sont relativement récentes à sur
la question vraiment simple banal de
dire mais où est-ce qu'on se contaminent
comment ce qu'on a mis sa vie en se
contaminent bien sûr à la fois par eux
royannez paroisse textile et tous nous
l'expression des mesures de des mesures
de protection mais c'est trois études
qui sont toutes les trois concordantes
et l'étude d'arnaud fontanet qui a été
réalisé d'abord dans une première
période sur la période du 1er au 15
octobre puis ensuite du 1er au 15
décembre puis ensuite maintenant sur la
période avec une une période de
restriction et de bd couvre-feu retrouve
son solide parce que l'on retrouve à
chaque fois finalement
les données qui peuvent eux qui peuvent
être faites
alors sur la notion d des flux et des
transports c'était là aussi une première
question oui après avoir dit qu'il ya
c'est aller le talion se contaminent ou
hôtel autres on double le risque n'est
pas ne paraît pas tellement plus
important chaque fois qu'il ya du
rassemblement un on multiplie dans une
certaine mesure le risque de
transmission ccc assez claire quand même
donc c'est une c'est une vraie question
mais inversement
inversement vous avez vu que on se
trouve dans une situation en france à la
fois vis-à-vis des verriers on n'est pas
seulement vis-à-vis des vagues alors
qu'eux-mêmes conte alice et je dirais la
circulation que vous évoquiez monsieur
le député sur deux se fait entre
différentes régions de france est bien
mal malgré cette gérer cette forme de
liberté dans une certaine mesure
vous avez des régions de france qui sont
beaucoup plus atteindre que l'autre et
donc qu'ils sont moins atteintes
c'est en partie lié au phénomène des
grandes et des grandes métropoles n'est
pas seulement pas seulement et vous
savez qu'il ya une sorte de carte on à
l'ouest de la france jusqu'à maintenant
est relativement protégé à la fois
vis-à-vis des variants et et de et de
niveaux de contamination relativement
élevé et qu'il ya une partie centrale et
s impliqué qui a été beaucoup plus
touchés
bon par ailleurs sur le le problème delà
des frontières c'est un sujet complexe
qui est sur lequel le et c'est un liste
europe et en suisse qu'à 20 ans est
pendu avec une vision européenne
ce que je peux vous dire moi je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas rentrer là dedans dans cette
discussion qui est une discussion
évidemment politique
je resterai dans sanitaires et pour vous
dire que le variés anglais il est déjà
en france 1 et essai il ya on a toujours
eu de la circulation avec l'angleterre
quand on peut imaginer qu'on va retarder
l'arrivée du variant sud africain dans
la métropole pendant un certain temps
mais il va finir par arriver parce qu'il
y aura des contaminations qui arriveront
de toute façon est par contre lille est
déjà arrivé parce qu'il y avait des
liens qu'ils étaient forts et l'eau
de quoi les couper parce que la fille du
chef jusqu'à maintenant les pays
africains étaient très peu touché par la
contamination
au nom de quoi des coupés avec la
réunion et avec eux et avec mayotte 1 c
et c'est donc c'est donc ce virus il est
transporté par les hommes
les hommes ont des contacts faut-il
bloquer l'ensemble de la circulation
c'est une question qui est politique et
sur laquelle je ne souhaite pas entrer
deuxièmement sur le financement de la
recherche le fait que nous n'ayons pas
de vaccin français entre guillemets et
là problème de souveraineté
bon ça chargeant une question à la fois
de la recherche académique des start up
qui ne dépasserait à ce soir mais aussi
deux des big pharma on a une très grande
big pharma en france qui est pourtant un
spécialiste de vaccin qui est sanofi et
qui pour des raisons diverses ils le
reconnaissent semaine a eu je dirais un
départ pas dans les meilleures
conditions sur la mise au point d'un
vaccin
il se lanterne de doses de vaccins yal
donc en effet nous ne sommes pas au
rendez vous de la production d'un vaccin
en plus qu'à dans l'immédiat c'est à
dire qu'on sera pas au rendez vous au
rendez vous à l'automne dans le
quatrième trimestre de l'année 2020
tient bon et pour l'instant donc c'est
en effet ces vaccins qui sont issus de
recherches académiques pour certains on
voit bien là strazeele et cas avec un
soir où de grandes start up comme comme
pfizer avec les start up allemande
ce ne sont pas en effet pour l'instant
un an parité je dirais issus de
recherches directement issus de
laboratoires français vous avez vu
également que le vaccin rougeole avec
porté par par le virus de la rougeole
s'est arrêté dans la collaboration qui
avait à l'institut pasteur entre la
situation et merck
parce que les premiers résultats
n'étaient pas suffisamment le solide par
rapport aux données déjà existantes par
les vaccins c'est la recherche c'est
leur chef et puis il y aura probablement
un retour de sanofi à un moment donné
alors est-ce que c'est lié aux problèmes
du financement marcha je veux pas me
lancer là dedans
sachez seulement je vous donne un
chiffre que
quand on regarde les publications sur le
co vide depuis le début de la pandémie
la france ya des des systèmes de
classement qui permet de le faire est en
cinquième position
c'est à dire c'est notre classement
assez habituel à vrai dire en étant
cinquième ou sixième position dans la
recherche en biologie ce sont des
données issues d'une étude
bibliométriques réalisé par reacting et
et l'inserm
les questions autour de la démocratie
sanitaire et de la communication matrix
ou mon seul on se connait nous sommes
connus au ccdh en effet c'est un domaine
qui fâchent
voilà que petit mais cher 1 ce triangle
de de construction entre le politique
qui décide
le scientifique qui est clair et le
citoyen qui donne aussi son éclairage et
je pense que la notion man et c'est de
cette démocratie en santé est construite
sur ce type
elle n'a pas été tellement rendez vous
10 ans le dans cette crise comines
parce que sidération parce que tout une
série de raisons parce que beaucoup de
top d'arn par certains côtés et on est
dans des situations de crise je le
regrette je suis comme vous nous avions
que le conseil scientifique avait
souhaité avoir la constitution d'un
comité citoyen de liaison je voulais
rappeler
finalement ça s'est fait ça s'est fait
avec eux le comité autour du lac ça et
surtout ça s'est fait en région
finalement c'est peut-être mieux ça soit
pas centralisé comme nous on avait une
idée centrale un peu trop d'ailleurs
et ça s'est fait en région vous avez ce
type de comités citoyens en relation et
des scientifiques existent à grenoble
quasi ça lyon est en train de se monter
à paris qui existe à strasbourg qui
existe à rennes et où il ya une
discussion avec les autorités régionales
les grandes malles et merle et les
responsables de grandes métropoles qui
s'est fait donc que elle existe elle est
arrivée avec un peu de retard et mais
elle est là elle existe sur ce dont on
m'accuse et sur les problèmes de
communication on m'accuse et je dirais
entre guillemets entre dire l'urgence et
l'extrême urgence non je maintiens ma
position
je nous n'avons le conseil scientifique
n'a jamais recommandé dès début janvier
relisez nos relisez no no no no texte
qu'il fallait rentrer dans le confit
demandé début janvier ça aurait été
qu'on a dit attention surveillants
voyant ce qui se passe après les fêtes
de noël et du 31 janvier regardons ce
qui se passe et il faut penser à avoir
une surveillance active à partir de la
mi janvier on a évoqué différents
scénarios en fonction de l'arrivée des
variants bon et puis je maintiens ma
position thiel pour eux sur une décision
vous voyez bien que la situation en ce
moment les services de réanimation ne
sont pas non plus totalement plein enfin
on on voit bien la tension qui peut y
avoir entre une vision sanitaire de dire
il faut absolument faire quelque chose
pour éviter pour éviter un drame
entre guillemets à l'animation à la fin
mars et puis de l'autre côté vous je
vous ai entendu aussi attention il ya la
santé mentale des plus jeunes
le il ya une acceptabilité en population
qui devient qui valait qui va devenir
difficile
donc on voit bien que c'est une ces deux
sens ce sont des décisions qui mérite
d'être pensé réfléchi construite et avec
des propositions c'est là où je voulais
indiqué le médecin le pauvre medecin que
je suis vous indiquer qu'il ya une
différence entre un yves herman 18 ans
qui vient de se planter sur le
périphérique
il faut trois équipes chirurgicales pour
le père et c'est dans l'eure et puis il
faut y aller vite et qui vous avez un
cas difficile qui demande à faire une
irm des examens radiologiques et on a
deux trois jours pour faire un
diagnostic et ya les dérange c'est ça
que je distingue entre l'extrême urgence
et l'urgence mais bien sûr qu'il ya
urgence à une semaine un ya urgence à
une semaine n'y a pas une semaine il ya
pas urgence à deux ou trois jours c'est
ça qu'il avait indiqué alors la maladie
parce que lead ou le coc vie de long oui
c'est une très bonne question c'est vrai
qu'on en parle un peu moins mais sachez
qu'il ya des recherches qui sont en
cours sur le sujet il ya plusieurs
cordes sur le suivi des patients que
vides de ce type qui existent qui sont
menées par la mairesse writing la
nouvelle agence de recherche qui existe
depuis le 1er janvier sur différentes
vous avez locales et les aspects
pulmonaire il y en a d'autres
il ya également des aspects
cardiovasculaires neurologique qui
existent psychique et qui existe et donc
y'a il y aura un colloque autour du coc
vide de longue durée du coc vie de long
qui sera organisée par la mairesse
reacting je dirais d'ici normalement en
fonction des événements bien sûr mais
d'ici le mois de mars et il ya des
relations entre sept corps et des
données que nous avons également avec
nos collègues le cas là également et nos
collègues onglet car eux sachez aussi
que dans la construction de recherche et
des questions de recherche
opérationnelle on essaie comme le comité
scientifique d'avoir énormément de
relations énormément en relation avec
les étrangers moi j'ai passé mon temps
là au cours des quinze derniers jours à
des call avec les anglais les sud
africains les brésiliens et les
californiens un plus plus qu'à la limite
avec le modèle français pour essayer de
me renseigner au maximum la question
finalement de est-ce qu'on a eu
d'évaluation des stratégies de
politiques publiques
et est ce qu'on est capable de dire si
un couvre-feu à 18 heures quelle quelle
conséquence il a un confinement là et tu
auras un confinement dur alors c'est une
vraie grande question est difficile dans
un contexte de crise et qui n'est pas
dans les habitudes françaises à
l'évaluation de politique de stratégie
de politique publique que ce soit dans
le domaine de la santé
on évalue finalement les décisions qui
ont été prises pour savoir de telle ou
telle façon
néanmoins là elles se sont elles se sont
faites elles se sont fait et ce qu'on
veut dire c'est par exemple sur votre
question autour du couvre-feu à 18
heures où on a maintenant une expérience
sur un certain nombre de territoires de
plus de façon un peu plus anciennes et
plus récentes y en a quatorze quinze
jours sur les plus récents il ya une
efficacité par un majeur mais à un petit
peu sur la circulation
je dirais du virus en général mais
aucune efficacité sur la circulation et
sur la pénétration des loriots voilà je
me lave est simple en terme de résumer
c'est à dire qu'on contrôle
globalement avec le couvre-feu qui est
déjà question de difficile à 18 heures
finalement une circulation du virus et
donc les conséquences qu'il peut y avoir
amélie néanmoins quand même avec
certaines zones c'est pas du tout
contrôler et on voit bien en particulier
en région paca ou en région franche
comté et où la circulation n'est
absolument pas le contrôler par le
couvre-feu à 18 heures il manque donc
quelque chose hélas une vient se
rajouter le problème le problème de la
pénétration du haillan est ce qu'une
stratégie de territoire pourrait être
mise en place
oui elle a été jusqu'à maintenant peu
appliquée après et nous l'avons en effet
recommandé comme un des scénarios
possibles c'est à dire d'avoir quelque
chose qui associerait un couvre-feu
strict voire une compris pendant le
week-end plus du confinement du
confinement sur cette zone régions qui
seraient particulièrement touchés look
avec une politique de territoire
alors elle est possible il faut qu'elle
soit pleinement bien expliquer là aussi
lorsque vous imaginez que les régions
qui qui sont confinés celle qu'ils ne
sont pas au nom de quoi
sur quels marqueur sur quels indices sur
quel le choc
sur quoi se basent ce type de les
sillons mais c'est explicable
il ya des marqueurs et c'est la question
que vous posez vous les connaissez
d'ailleurs ils sont données sur
lesquelles on pourrait s'appuyer et en
particulier un des marques à vous avez
bien compris qui va être très important
là dans les semaines qui viennent
c'est le pourcentage de variants 1 dans
tel ou tel dans telle ou telle zone
et qui va être particulier en importe
après par rapport à une stratégie plus
globale de type l'ensemble du territoire
là c'est à mes yeux véritablement si une
décision début politique alors sur
l'ensemble des questions monsieur mila
nigloo m'avait posée à la fin lettré
pont ça c'est une excellente question
parce qu'on est focalisée sur les
vaccins et je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
où l'avez peut-être pas noté je croyais
beaucoup période des traitements qu à
l'arrière
pourquoi parce que les vaccins vont vont
permettre de protéger les plus anciens
contre les formes graves mais d'abord on
va pas tous les protéger et donc qu'est
ce qu'on fait
je dirai à la fois pour ceux qui n'ont
pas bien répondu au axa et en attendant
qu'ils soient vaccinés
est ce qu'une des solutions en effet ne
serait pas de traiter immédiatement les
plus anciens de façon à réduire la
mortalité morbidité
alors on sait ce qu'on a des outils
alors on a on commence alors d'abord on
a une longue période sans traitement je
le laissais ma position est écrite dans
le dans un avis du conseil scientifique
de juillet on a attendu d'avoir
l'ensemble de résultats des grands
essais internationaux
je dirais pour prendre une position
claire nous n'avons pas de médicaments
spécifiques ayant fait la preuve de son
efficacité directement dirigés contrôle
qu vide jusqu'à la période du mois de
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
en tout cas 2000 ba1 donc c'est vrai
pour l'hydraulique l'origine c'est vrai
pour le rem désir c'est vrai pour eux
les anciens traitement du vih comme les
kaletra il n'y a pas de traitement alors
quelles sont les nouvelles on a les
anticorps les cocktails d'anticorps
monoclonaux qui sont des anticorps
dirigés contre certaines protéines du
virus y ans parce qu est la protéine
spike qui viennent la donne lors de
trois essais de faire la preuve de leur
efficacité qui doivent être donné très
tôt très tôt parce que en fait une des
vraies questions autour des traitements
c'est non seulement les molécules qu'on
utilise
mais c'est le moment où on les donne
vous savez qu'il ya plusieurs parties
dans cette maladie et à une partie
virale qui ensuite ya une partie
inflammatoires et après il ya une partie
pour les formes d des formes graves et
si on donne ces anticorps monoclonaux
sur sur ses succès de façon très précoce
on peut je dirais bloquer la bloquer la
multiplication du virus
un deuxième traitement est probablement
tourner autour des traitements par
l'interféron 1 et sur lesquelles il ya
ainsi une série interféron alpha ou
interféron bêta et sur lequel il ya une
série d'essais qui démarre suite à des
études de physio pathogénique un
français jean laurent cazes et loire qui
a qui a pu mettre en évidence mécanisme
de défaut et de production de
l'interféron particulier dans les formes
graves et puis on a une troisième
on a on a deux
ou de nouvelles molécules de deuxième ou
de troisième génération c'est-à-dire
directement ciblés comme antiviraux
contre le virus three men qui sont en
phase 1 et 2 sur lequel je peux rien
dire mais sachez qu'il ya la recherche
dessus et puis enfin on a des stratégies
qui pourraient s'appuyer sur les sérums
issus de convalescent et où deux
convalescents vacciner c'est à dire pays
qui ont une réponse militaire
extrêmement forte poussée éventuellement
par le vaccin et qui pourraient être
utilisés donc voilà sur la transparence
sur la vitamine d dans les traitements
oui
les données sont pas sont pas je dirais
ma silva sûr mais je veux dire on est
tous en particulier chez les sujets âgés
le monde a gelé pendant la période
olympique d'hiver plutôt en carence de
vitamine d donc à condition de pas se
voit une vitamine d tout les jours qui
peut entraîner une pathologie 1 et de
prendre raisonnablement sa son ampoule
de calais qu'elle s'y faire une fois par
mois
eh bien ça ne peut pas faire de mal je
dirais dans la lutte globale contre le
virus
mais il faut être prudent surtout de ne
pas prendre de la vitamine t tous les
jours parce que les intoxications la
vitamine d ça existe la transparence et
la biblio oui c'est mais le les avis du
bureau du comité scientifique sont sur
le site du ministère on n'a pas de site
propre de ils sont payants ils sont
parfaitement donc accessible au grand
public
la biblio sur les études
épidémiologiques sur lesquels on
s'appuie et dont nos avis à une
biographie en général dans la plupart de
nos avis et puis par ailleurs le site de
basterds wee aa démobilisateur qui est
issu de l'institut pasteur a mis aussi
sur nous sur le fameux ces fameux calcul
en effet de survenue d'incidence
d'hospitalisation ils sont maintenant
public depuis
depuis des lieux décents confiner les
plus âgées
c'est un débat difficile un jeu je le
présenterai autrement je dirais que dans
le contexte actuel proposé aux personnes
les plus âgées les plus fragiles
de d'effectuer une sorte d'auto
isolement ou de protection plutôt
appeler comme ça d'auto protection
individuelle il peut être proposé
mais c'est à eux de décider c'est eux
qui décident
ce n'est pas pas et on est là on doit
demander dans le respect de la personne
ce sont eux qui décident et c'est leur
rappeler en effet que ça ça ce que je
lui dise sur la contamination
la contamination est possible y compris
chez soi à domicile pour une personne
qui pense se protéger qui à la limite ne
va plus faire ses courses mais accueille
une de personnes chez elles sans prendre
de précautions il faut ils font pas la
coupé du reste de 2,2 de son tissu
social
on est tous d'accord là dessus mais lui
rappeler les règles de protection y
compris chez elle et au moment des repas
en particulier donc est-ce que ça
suffirait
c'est la deuxième question sa stratégie
cta réponse est non parce que et
heureusement
et heureusement il ya une porosité entre
générateur générationnel en france qui
existe entre la population la plus jeune
les parents et les grands-parents et ctc
c'est une et il faut on va pas le
changer et donc il ya cette porosité
conduit à partir du moment où on a trop
de circulation du virus dans la
population jeune à une transmission
progressive dans la population la
puisaye on a toutes les données là
dessus qu'ils montent cette porosité
dans ce qui s'est passé au mois de
septembre sur un certain nombre de
grandes métropoles où on voit au départ
une transmission une circulation du
virus uniquement la population jeune
avec ce qui s'est passé au début des
rentrées universitaires etc
et puis progressivement ça rentre dans
la population la plus âgée je rappelle
que la suède qui a eu cette attitude
finalement de de laisser vivre entre
guillemets en auto isolant plus ou moins
bien d'ailleurs les populations âgées
est revenue complet complètement à 180°
sur sa stratégie
il ya il ya maintenant deux mois voilà
bah écoutez je crois que j'ai répondu à
peu près à à une série de vocations
j'avais encore j'ai encore noté quoi les
conflits d'intérêts par les conflits
d'intérêts
hossa du le complotisme des conflits
d'intérêts oui à ne confondons pas une
fois de plus d'aidé ce qui est conflits
d'intérêts et ce qu'est la déclaration
la déclaration d'intérêts oui bien sûr
je lui ai demandé à l'ensemble des
membres du conseil scientifique
c'est il ya un règlement intérieur
d'ailleurs qui est disponible également
sur le site et commencer à celle que
l'intéressé à l'aspect des traitements
jeu comme je voulais indiqué sana n'a
pas pas ça la pikes à ne pas y a pas
tellement eu finalement d'enjeux majeurs
là dessus néanmoins j'ai demandé quand
même à deux ou trois personnes chaque
fois qu'on parlait des traitements de se
retirer de la discussion et de se mettre
ce qu'on appelle en débord et on l'a
fait très très régulièrement
moi même je déclare que je n'ai pas de
conflit d'intérêts est ce que je me suis
fait vacciner
la réponse est oui et je me suis fait
vacciner
je rappelle que j'ai 72 ans donc que je
n'ai pas droit au vaccin mais que je
suis soignants puisque j'ai une
consultation à bicêtre et que c'est à ce
titre là en tant que soignant ayant une
consultation dans mon hôpital que j'ai
été vacciné
c'est une preuve j'ai eu une première
vaccination avec le vaccin
kaiser écoutez je crois que j'ai répondu
à peu près à l'ensemble de nos questions
je confirme alors sur la dans toute la
liste que j'avais que j'avais que
j'avais marqué juste la solidité des
études des dossiers montés par pfizer
modern à travers le l'ensemble écoutez
je ne la question serait plus en fait
pour alain fischer ou marie paule kieny
qui ont étudié en détail dans le détail
non seulement les publications que moi
j'ai vu bien sûr mais le dossier
d'enregistrement inquiets auquel ils ont
eu accès sont des dossiers qui font 500
600 pages etc
pour en avoir discuté avec eux en tout
cas pour les deux dossiers à mérida il
semble que ça soit des dossiers
extrêmement solide après on est dans une
atmosphère de pression d'accélération
éventuellement des dossiers d'aena
ce qui me rassure un peu c'est vous
voyez le délai avec lequel ce que prend
en particulier l'agencé européenne pour
donner un feu vert pour le vaccin
astrazeneca
alors certains prennent ce set ce cet
état en disant regardez une fois de plus
comme les européens sont lents pour
donner un feu vert
on peut aussi se dire que peut-être ci
ne donne pas le feu vert aussi
rapidement que ça c'est que le dossier
le pose un certains nombre peut-être de
questions sur la totale solidité de ce
vaccin et sur le fait qu'il n'est
peut-être pas tout à fait à la hauteur
que les temps avec ça intéressant
néanmoins probablement il est peut-être
pas à la hauteur en termes de résultats
des deux vaccins et reda donc il ya
quand même un processus d'évaluation qui
est sous pression et c'est là où il faut
faire attention à la fois au niveau 2 de
leur or et de l'avis des américaines les
nous a eu que pour la première fois ci
je trouve ça très important de sa charge
les aspects de démocratie sanitaire
l'afd a rendu à fait la discussion
publique de l'acceptation des règles
saint fighter et des vaccins des vaccins
moderna je croise était 10 heures de
séance et deezer cd public et c'était
sur le net
c'est la première fois que ça arrive
elle a étudié ou en général on considère
que ce type de discussion est d'ordre
scientifique et un peu privé par
certains côtés et là ils ont souhaité le
rendre public
c'est aussi une des forces c'est qu'on
l'a beaucoup discuté récemment et de la
démocratie américaine
je pense qu'il faut qu'on en prenne un
certain nombre de leçons moi c'est un de
mes regrets je vais vous dire c'est un
peu tard puis c'est difficile mais c'est
de ne pas c'est de ne pas d'une certaine
mesure rend de temps en temps des
séances du comité scientifique publique
[Musique]